frente a la pulverización de sus
salarios profesores trabajadores
públicos y sindicalistas venezolanos
salieron a las calles de Caracas para
reclamar ingresos dignos el año pasado
El Ejecutivo fijó el salario mínimo en
130 bolívares que equivalían entonces a
unos 30 dólares pero debido a la
inflación se han visto reducidos a poco
más de cinco dólares según el centro de
documentación y análisis social de la
Federación de maestros una canasta
básica cuesta ahora alrededor de 90
salarios mínimos
que nosotros queremos trabajar que
nosotros Queremos formar a este país
pero no pasando hambre la marcha se
produce una semana después de que el
ministro del petróleo anunciara su
dimisión esto cuando las autoridades
investigan la presunta corrupción entre
funcionarios públicos de la industria
petrolera Estatal y miembros del
gobierno los manifestantes
exigen ahora que los funcionarios rinden
cuenta
al gobierno para tener yate tienen
mansiones el pueblo está esperando
para saquear seguir saqueando al país
hay real para pagar a los trabajadores
el fiscal general de Venezuela informó
de una veintena de detenidos incluidos
altos funcionarios del gobierno del
presidente Nicolás maduro y líderes
empresariales la mayoría de ellos
relacionados con la trama de corrupción
dentro de la estatal petrolera el sábado
Los partidarios de maduro habían
manifestado para expresar su apoyo a
esta Cruzada anticorrupción con el lema
los honestos somos más
[Música]